en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca de la
elasticidad de la demanda le voy a poner
aquí elasticidad elasticidad de la
demanda de la demanda demanda y eso
básicamente es como impacta el precio en
la cantidad demandada de un cierto bien
acá tenemos una gráfica en donde tenemos
el precio en pesos y acá tenemos la
cantidad y se trata de tacos si este es
el precio de cada taco y aquí es la
cantidad demandada ésta de acá es la
curva de demanda entonces lo que
queremos ver es como un cambio en el
precio modifica la cantidad de tacos que
se venden entonces le voy a poner así le
voy a poner es como un cambio en el
precio cambio
en precio impacta la cantidad demandada
impacta la cantidad que voy a poner a mi
cantidad demandada demandada va ok
entonces bueno en términos así concretos
los economistas a lo que nos referimos
con elasticidad de la demanda bueno la
verdad yo no soy economista pero digo ya
que estamos haciendo economía pues
podemos jugar a que los hombros pero
entonces la elasticidad de la demanda en
términos concretos es igual al cambio en
la cantidad demandada es decir es igual
al cambio lo voy a poner si el cambio
pero no cualquier cambio sino el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad cantidad
dividido me quedo un poco chueco pero
dividido entre el cambio cambio
porcentual en el precio y lo primero que
te debes de estar preguntando es por qué
le ponemos un cambio porcentual y no
simplemente pasemos digamos cambio de en
cantidad dividido entre cambio en precio
y bueno la razón es que tiene que ver
con las unidades cuando hacemos un
cambio porcentual eso nos quita
totalmente las unidades porque como
dividimos entre 1
la cantidad base que ahorita vamos a ver
que es un poco más complicado que
usualmente pero como dividimos en la
cantidad base se cancelan las unidades y
por tanto esto nos da un numerito ya sin
unidades muy bien entonces bueno porque
se llamará elasticidad bueno tiene mucho
que ver con con la elasticidad con el
concepto físico de elasticidad en física
si tenemos una liga voy a poner ahí una
liga y aplicamos una cierta fuerza y se
estira poquito entonces decimos que la
liga es poco elástica sin embargo si
tenemos una liga que al aplicarle
digamos la misma cantidad de fuerza se
estira más entonces decimos que es muy
elástica pasa algo muy similar acá en
términos económicos
tenemos bienes muy elásticos y muy
elásticos decimos que un bien es muy
elástico plástico
elástico si pasa lo siguiente si un
cierto cambio porcentual en el precio
causa causa le voy a poner un alto
cambio porcentual en la cantidad en la
cantidad demandada y voy a decir que es
muy inelástico muy elástico elástico si
pasa lo justo lo contrario déjame bajar
tantito si si un cambio porcentual en el
precio causa
causa un bajo cambio porcentual en la
cantidad entonces es básicamente que los
términos físicos solo que acá aplicamos
fuerza y nos fijamos en el estiramiento
pero acá aplicamos un cambio en el
precio y nos fijamos en el cambio en la
cantidad demandada bueno déjame hacer
específicamente pues el ejemplo para
este caso de acá para esta tabla porque
vamos a ver unas ciertas cosas con con
esto de calcular el porcentaje o en el
cambio en el porcentaje que es un poco
distinto a lo que se hace usualmente
entonces déjame borrar por acá abajo
para tener espacio para trabajar voy a
borrar estas ligas y voy a borrar está
también la borró ahorita la vamos a
volver a escribir esta de aquí la borró
y también voy a borrar el concepto
físico de acá
digo la interpretación económica del
concepto físico bueno entonces voy a
borrar esto ok a y ya tengo más espacio
y entonces ahora sí vamos a pasar a la
tabla vamos a ver qué nos dice nuestra
tabla mirá acá el precio cambio de 9 a 8
entonces imagínate mira aquí ya puse
estas columnas de elasticidad de demanda
y elasticidad de demanda en un valor
absoluto entonces bueno aquí vamos a
ponerla y aquí la vamos a poner sin
signo después vamos a platicar qué
quiere decir tanto ésta como su valor
absoluto pero vamos a ver cuánto cambio
entonces imagínate que queremos calcular
esta la elasticidad de la demanda para
cuando pasamos de a ave entonces déjame
tomar el color de a entonces queremos
calcular la elasticidad de la demanda de
a ave ok entonces que tendríamos que
hacer pues tenemos que poner arriba el
cambio del cambio porcentual en la
cantidad y dividir entre el cambio
porcentual entre el precio entonces
empecemos con el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad
qué le pasó a la cantidad pues pasó de
ser 2 a ser 4 verdad aumentamos en 4
digo para eso aumentamos en 2 de 2 a 4
es aumentar en 2
entonces pasó de ser 2 a ser 4 pero qué
pasó con el precio el precio disminuyó
en 1 ok entonces vamos a ponerle aquí
arriba tenemos que poner el cambio en la
cantidad que es 2 pero es el cambio
porcentual y aquí es donde es importante
porque usualmente al hacer un cambio
porcentual dividimos entre una cierta
base pero esa base así casi siempre es
un extremo este 2 este 4 aquí en la
economía cómo se hace es más bien que se
divide entre el promedio de los dos
entre promedio de 2 y 4 y esto es
básicamente para tener la misma
elasticidad de ave que debe a pero bueno
vamos a hacerlo así y hábitat le piensas
tantito entonces tenemos que pasarlo al
porcentaje hay que dividir entre el
promedio de 2 y 43
y multiplicamos por 100 para que se haga
un porcentaje y luego abajo tenemos que
poner el cambio porcentual en el precio
el cambio en el precio es menos 1 para
pasarlo a términos porcentuales
dividimos entre el promedio de 8 y 9 o
sea entre 8.5
y multiplicamos por 100 muy bien
entonces vamos a hacer esta cuenta de
aquí esté 100 se cancela con este 100
aquí estamos dividiendo entre una
fracción que es lo mismo que multiplicar
por su inverso nos queda dos tercios
multiplicado por 8.5 dividido entre
menos 12 por 8.52 por 8 es 16 y otro que
se acumule es 17 nos va a quedar este
menos de acá menos diecisiete tercios
y haber diecisiete tercios es y esto es
igual a menos esto es 15 tercios o sea
es menos cinco con dos tercios menos
cinco y dos tercios que es lo mismo que
menos cinco puntos 666 666 con mucho 63
pero lo voy a poner menos 5.67 y le
pongo aproximadamente ba entonces esto
de acá claro esto lo pudimos haber
sacado con una calculadora que es la
forma más práctica pero como es dos
tercios podemos saber cuánto da bueno
estos efectos de acá es la elasticidad
de la demanda queda menos 5.67 muy bien
el valor absoluto sería quitarle el
signo 5.67 y aquí ya tenemos el valor
absoluto y te dejo que cheques que da lo
mismo calcular la elasticidad de ave y
debe a que es lo mismo y que no nos
daría lo mismo si tuviera si tomáramos
el extremo inicial como pues como la
base para sacar el porcentaje bueno
vamos a seguir haciendo las cuentas para
los otros dos casos y en el siguiente
vídeo platicamos de pues qué significan
estos numeritos
vamos a pasar para acá ahora queremos la
elasticidad de la demanda pero ahora ya
no es pasando de ave antes calculamos
pasando de ave pero ahora queremos
pasando de c a de o de de hace va a dar
lo mismo por la forma en la cual lo
estamos sacando entonces cuánto le
cuánto nos da aquí otra vez la cantidad
de aumenta en 2 y el precio disminuye en
1 pasa lo mismo que arriba entonces a lo
mejor uno podría pensar que va a dar lo
mismo la elasticidad de la demanda pero
no porque al pasarlo a términos
porcentuales va a cambiar entonces
haciendo la cuenta y está la elasticidad
de la demanda es igual al cambio
porcentual
entonces otra vez es 2 pero ahora ya no
dividimos entre 3 como antes sino entre
el promedio de 9 y 11 que es 10
10 dividido entre menos uno menos uno
dividido entre el promedio de 4.5 y 5.5
4.5 y 5.5 es 10 entre 12 5 bayas 5 está
el número que queda entre estos dos
números entonces me queda menos 1 entre
5 esto es lo mismo que dos décimos
multiplicado por 50 -1 2 por 5 el 10
entre 10 es 1 con este menos se hace un
-1
muy bien entonces la elasticidad de la
demanda al pasar de c a d o desde hace
es menos 1 y en valor absoluto es una
excelente ya nada más nos queda una
cuentita más vamos a pasar ahora del
precio de 2 a 1 es decir de la situación
que al aire entonces aquí de nuevo el
precio baja en 1 la cantidad aumenta en
2 y cuánto nos queda la elasticidad de
la demanda la elasticidad de la demanda
es de nuevo cambio en 2 pero hay que
dividir entre el promedio de 16 y 18
entre 17
y acá abajo tenemos que dividir entre
menos 1 entre y ahora el promedio de 1 y
2 es 1.5 eso es lo mismo que 2 entre 17
x 1.5
punto 5 dividido entre menos 1 para
entonces esté menos se pasa para cada
dos veces 1.5 estrés y 17 por 1 el 17
excelente ahí estoy acá cuánto será no
sé muy bien pero es aproximadamente es
más o menos 17 por 18 está cerquita de
300 entonces esto es como menos 0.18
claro si tuviéramos una calculadora lo
podríamos hacer así tecleando verdad y
sería lo más práctico entonces aquí le
pongo menos 0.18 y en valor absoluto es
0.18 ok entonces ahí tenemos las tres
elasticidad es de demanda pasando de a a
b de c a d y d
efe y para sacar los cambios
porcentuales recuerda que tenemos que
dividir entre el promedio no entre
ninguno de los extremos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo para platicar un poco
que quieren decir estas cantidades y qué
interpretación podemos darle a esto de
que aunque nos movamos lo mismo nos dan
diferentes relatividad es de demanda